[Applause]
hello everyone I just reached 1000
subscribers and I'd like to thank you
all for that
and for achieving this goal I decided to
share a very special game with you it's
a game played by mikael tile against
Alexis wedding
the game is called not bad for a dead
man now I don't really know where the
game is called not bad for a dead man I
try to find out but I couldn't do it so
if any of you know why the game is
called the death please do let me know
so yeah here we go
it all had the white pieces and alexei
had the black pieces top played efore c5
Knight f3 d6
the shamanic Sicilian d4c takes d4
Knight d4 we have a 6 Bishop to d3 9e 7
Knight to c3 Knight B to c6 Knight be $3
wants to keep his pieces on the board of
course so he could do his thing you know
Knight to g6 tile castles b5 Bishop to
e3 d6f for Bishop to e7 Queen to h5 yes
of course tile is going to play Queen to
h5 you know even even though she isn't
doing anything there now it's always
good to have your queen on e4 n h5
Bishop to f6 Ruby did the rook a to d1
Alexa captured the knight on c3 B takes
c3 and now Queen c7 roopd - and now
Knight C to the e7 ok yeah this is the
position where everything starts to get
interesting top plays Knight to d4
Bishop to d7 and we have our first
double f5
Aleksey took an f5 talk actually takes
f5 nice the e4 95 and here at all
sacrifices a night so the threat is
capturing the Queenan c7 and also
capturing the pawn on g7 of course black
captured Bishop takes East 6f takes c6
and up like a black South pawn is pinned
he can't recapture in here black plays
g6 he wants to get rid of the Queen and
then recapture on e6 but here is the
move tall so when he played f5 win takes
e5 capturing the night and also
threatening the rock threatening and f7
threatening everything in the style of
tau black except it is Queen sacrifice
and tall token f7 and here Alexei
resigned
if King to f6 then 15 to f8 top plays
Bishop h6 checkmate and if King to d8
Todd will play pawn to f8 Queen check
after capturing the Queen rook takes FA
to check in 37 Bishop f5 discovered
double check from rook and the bishop he
has to go to c6 and now Bishop a4 check
and here I'm pretty sure that this is
the position towel so when played f5 now
black has no moves he can he can play
Knight D 95 but after white recaptures
white white captures the rook on a8 it's
all over Black has no moves and it's
game over
so yeah this is a just another tall game
another spectacular another spectacular
attacking game where tau sacrifices
everything
and with the game so yeah if you're ever
feeling sad or you know you don't have
the will to do anything just watch a
couple of towel games and you'll feel
right better see you in some of my next
videos
[Music]